hero candidate coming to this village, and
I met him yesterday, so it seems like they're looking for a
refreshingly good-looking man and a skilled magician to defeat the demon lord.That's
surprising considering he's a hero candidate.  He must be a
fine human being, and that's the kind of person you'd see in a heroic tale.
Someday,
as a magician, I'll
belong to a party full of hero candidates, and I'll
face any difficulties head-on, and I'll never resort to cowardly
or arrogant methods.  I hope to be fair and honest,
and with my magic, I will blow away the Demon King's executives and make the
world roar.
When I finally destroy the Demon King,
I will be the new Demon King, Megumin, and I will sit on the throne as Megumin.
[Laughs]
- What's wrong? You
suddenly burst into laughter. It's okay. I was thinking about something
important and wasn't listening.